you recently opened up about getting
back into the dating game which I
thought was very brave and awesome have
you found someone I'm enjoying my time
yeah what are you looking for this time
around um somebody who is honest loyal
trustworthy fun can turn up make even a
trip to the coast restore an adventure
oh that would be me so the guy needs to
be really deserving of me last question
the talk is gearing up to welcome a new
co-host as a woman in daytime what's
your advice I think that we have so much
room for all the types of personalities
and experiences we should have in
daytime in television in period I grew
up with their words like to Sally Jessy
Raphael and Oprah so I'd like to see
more and as many women that can come out
here and share the space we all have
room because we're all competing against
ourselves be the best version of
yourself there's no other competition to
that you know it's widely rumored to be
Marie Osmond are you a Maria Marie
Osmond Marie Osmond is really cool Marie
whatever it is you're doing to keep
yourself in check pass all the info to
me girl
I want those numbers
[Music]